Hey, I am Destin if there is one video you want to share about the eclipse make it this one.
Top 10 things you need to know about eclipse day
In just a couple of minutes.
Number 1 - Know where you're going watch the eclipse from.
There is this thing called the "totality plane". If you're
inside of it, you see a total eclipse.
If you're outside, you see a partial eclipse.
Don't freak out about getting right on the mid-line,
If you're a little bit away from it, it's OK,
You're gonna have a very good experience.
Plan on traffic, take extra food.
And extra water.
Number 2 - Know exactly when
the eclipse is going to happen. Download this app,
Solar Eclipse Timer. It's going to talk to you
through the eclipse. Android,
Apple. Click this button to locate
where you are inside the totality plane.
Click this button.
You are now ready to listen to the events
of the eclipse.
Number 3 - Know exactly
what the times mean. C1 is
when the Moon first touches the Sun. About an hour,
hour and a half later, C2 is when
the total eclipse starts.
C3 is when the total eclipse ends.
And C4 is the end of the
eclipse, the Moon leaves the Sun.
Number 4 - Make sure you have your solar glasses.
Know how to use them. The only time
you can take them off is between C2 and C3,
total eclipse. Make sure they're
"Safe for Direct Solar Viewing".
Number 5 - If you're going to take pictures,
you have to use a filter.
You're going to want to take off that filter about
20 seconds before C2.
You're also going to have to change your settings because
the light is changing and you want to be
able to take pictures of the Corona.
Have a plan.
Number 6 - Look for
Shadow Bands. They're like shadow snakes on the ground
just before and just after the eclipse.
If you're going to video it, lay out a white sheet,
know where North is. It's really interesting
and scientists don't know why they happen.
Number 7 - Observe the environment around you.
Temperature is going to drop, crickets are going to chirp,
animals are going to do weird things,
people are going to get really excited.
Watch the stuff around you.
Number 8 -
If you're a photographer, there's 3 things you want to get.
The Diamond Ring, Bailey's Beads,
and the Corona. I made a video on how to do that.
Number 9 - At max totality, get your
face away from the gear and just
take it all in. The 360° horizon
is going to be coloured.
It's going to be amazing. That's the moment where
you just need to experience it, interact with your family,
I'm excited about that part.
Number 10 - Tell other people, if they know
exactly the cool science stuff to look
for during the eclipse, it going to be
a way more awesome experience.
So tell people. I've left a checklist
at smartereveryday.com/eclipse
Go get that and use it on
Eclipse Day. I hope you love it
I hope you have a great time.
That's all the information I could cram into a very short video about the eclipse
Please consider sharing this with anybody
that's gonna go.
I know we think about sharing videos, actually share
this one because this will completely enhance
people's experience. I'm Destin,
You're getting Smarter Every Day.
Have a good one. Please share the video.
I'd appreciate it. Bye ! I am practicing
how to be sad because
of clouds. So I'm ready for the eclipse !
Owww....
Yeah, it's working.